[Music]
all right here it is the moment you've
been waiting for the saddest party on
the Citadel is about to begin
oh boy I'm here with John Luke is always
and let's see how this one plays I am
really excited thank you everyone for
watching for getting us to this point
yea-ah we're about to ruin one of my
favorite DLC that's very generous not
really no it's not it is super dot I'm
here dying but have fun get drunk yeah
it's like a piano I mean look at the
view view which is going away for some
reason fireplace a bar that's the dream
is having like a bar yeah Baldwin
Shepherd sure does does love bars now I
don't necessarily need to have the
waterfall uh although it would be nice
if that'd be cool I could do without
that the part of the rooms neat little
touch as well yeah Jennifer wants to get
some sushi [ __ ] that we have to go
really after you though change your
armor do watch and driver one last time
do we want to modify anything I mean
we're in the helmet the helmet has to
stay
yeah that's staying like that
bright-green fixed occasionally bad yeah
let's do it
that's good
[Music]
man they really went all out with this
DLC yeah they did
I mean like a fancy suit now no no
Thorin are still leather jacket hey
commander up here I'd recognize that
face anywhere there's a girl like ah why
the Batman get a skip a line come in
till Shifu you'll save it is later 1
megohm French yeah there's a great
commander really with an aquarium
on the floor ah commander shepard i'm
staff analyst my road Alliance
alliance intelligence there are people
trying to kill you yeah I think you've
aware that look look at my face new
people there if someone is hacking your
account comm channels personal records
they're targeting you specifically big
mistake oh man there's the angry face
it's always an angry face excuse me you
thought fennel is official that was it
she's like of the Penguins gun
excuse me my view of the parties being
in Dark Knight
yeah by the crew I'm going after her
find the crew hi hmm biotic choice he is
bait go you used me as bait
oh come on buzzer doesn't that's a
Baldwin Shepard move right there yeah
you can't be surprised oh yeah you get
this like silenced island off his goal I
like this gun yeah it's cool
straight out of Uncharted we're like a
die hard yeah I'm fine
might give a little back so we're just
getting Liara by default but this was
cool were you a dumb you would get your
romance option would be the one who
would yeah this deal seems a great
example of uh
it's not multiple playthroughs at the
very least like looking up the alternate
dialog because there's so much alternate
dialogue they've written just for this
DLC it's kind of ridiculous a whole
bunch of dialog we won't experience no
one to have that we won't experience any
of it
good to hear things are a little day the
crew has been you and James have a suite
the whole crew everyone's here hello
could you please open the gate
thank you please leave is that because
of the gun fires because of Baldwin Jeff
I don't want to die he's gonna kill me
it's a good foulest impression thank you
let's have to sound really nipply oh
there's when a Rex would show up oh yeah
she does look like a minigun or
something it's really cool so what
happens now we're about to find out they
show up with a mini holiday shotgun
did he take the minigun I don't know
what happens you have no idea
James what a disappointment we're
running out of options here he's gonna
show up now eating and then what
that's it literally it Jay get down here
not even to thank you did your ass down
here James
Glyph collating relevant Intel for
review doctor to Sony Thanks
alright the doc is on the case what
about the rest of the crew yeah what
about those slackers is that it mr.
Lincoln aren't they all suppose my god
they even get the plural ahh that was
pretty good oh this is why we do this
this is why we did all this Shepard
dance dance baldwin dance
yeah he knows what's up maybe
surveillance camera caught it anyway oh
my god his head I found something
we can gather the team whenever you're
ready yeah the whole team hey everyone
get over here so that's our identity
thief yes
using disguisers on a public terminal no
leads there I feel like there's supposed
to be someone in between them
yeah the please yeah really weird and
you're right or maybe they were just
waiting from the fallback in the
navigation yeah there's definitely
supposed to be a lot more people around
us like like there should be someone
there on the right that would actually
be a funnier way to do this is a play it
with all the characters but then like
find a way to mod to delete those
characters from like showing up in
cutscenes or like gameplays those does
everyone pretending that the whole squad
is there but there's no one there
there's pauses for where their dialogue
would be okay who'd want to bring a lot
of options here
uh James yo screeching look I got us a
Hughes in the suit
[Music]
- looking fine commander to get the face
as is in case you need to stop the truck
oh my god the game knows I can't believe
the gamers acknowledge that we have a
horrible face holy [ __ ]
straight to the bar nothing too creative
I want to be able to walk a straight a
lot not definitely not oh my god
right so there's this fish with
hallucinogenic skin we get n our buzzed
right up
what happens if humans eat way more coke
and it releases into our system slowly
that's the clear your schedule for the
entire week am dang I want to be L see
where you just get to try weird space
drugs
I do love weird space drugs and I feel
like there have been games of really
like delve deep into we're just basing
all about that which is why I want my
gareth standalone CSEC dlc or a game
because you could just make a whole like
thing about like him trying to crack
down on the on the mine fish drugs or
what exactly space narcotics what are
you saying see you sick biscuit because
it's like Seabiscuit alright I like that
all the way are all the way Baldwin
Shepard does not go halfway yeah well
we're gonna we can never buy anything in
this game anyway I don't know which
one's ours is ours is the one and last
yet yeah its second the last
dang it I'm like I've ever actually won
at this minigame it's just luck keeps
going until we win all right yeah oh oh
CSEC biscuit you you not he's gonna lose
I can already tell it's over oh wait
wait yeah full of ass he's booked
whoa oh man tastes like chicken
oh yes yeah look at Baldwin man is he
he's just a man Oh James bear
oh let's gamble more gambling all right
uh I don't know how to gamble Oh me yeah
I'm not sure what we're looking at here
ah
pick a number put 11 put it all yeah
sure but at all 11 [ __ ]
I think that it isn't what we wanted
gotta keep going till we win
why right fresh I'm put it all on reddit
yeah we'll go ready I'll go right again
yeah I'll be right there Brooks yeah
this is sorry on the left oh man we have
to win again just to see that that's a
good animation
I love that animation one more time
are we like getting anything or is our
reward his reaction I don't know I'm not
happy though what the hell I guess he's
gonna have to retire for health reasons
nice one James funny
nailed it then what are you going to do
stop the Reapers because I'm pretty sure
you can't only Baldwin Chevrolet ball -
ever I can stop the Reapers
you can stop a truck with his face and
the Reapers with his face yeah so cool
party but I shouldn't read anything into
being your date right because Jimmy's
vague is all about the lady all right
all right
sorry Wow okay Janice geez Chinese so
nice for a friend huh just once in my
life I was not necessary for the success
of the mission ship where is in their
head why do they keep doing that though
the data fruit structure with a rate the
logic integrity remains viable it's so
sad okay here's everyone again you're
the crew of the Normandy you're legends
to the rest of the Alliance it was
mostly me yes we should definitely say
that I kind of want to know legends can
be good The Legend of Baldwin Shepherd
all of us all four of us I think more of
them are flying at me you know killed a
badass first and the fight gets easy god
James shut up I wish I wish you could
have died the friendship become rodder
II I thought this bunch everything they
know all of it involving new and novel
ways to die I might add
here we evolving novel ways to die I
mean wait that was really that line like
can she say that
if you don't kill everyone because that
seems like a real snap at the fact that
I've murdered everyone because new and
novel ways to die is definitely the
alternative name for this year but uh
who gets to take point with you that's
supposed to be he like everyone to come
on like you know no do you get to pick
from all your squad members still alive
normally yeah even like if even if like
Jack or whatever or I don't know well
they're not they're not in at this point
it's just like so basically it's like
you get a pic and you you pick normally
but then everyone else is up in the raft
yeah very good answer so this like it
doesn't make any sense because it's like
you're just leaving one person behind
yeah that's it
I guess who do we leave behind James
yeah well he got his time it he he kind
of offended us too in hue yeah did a
nice thing for him and tried to be a
smartass forgot about the helmet oh boy
so yeah who's going to be shooting in
the rest this is the mission I'm really
excited I really wanna do this plays out
all like the squad banter disken force
the archives is somewhere below it again
there's just supposed to be a lot more
people I think even one shot
yeah the cool factor of this mission not
really not really hitting it also did
you see that yeah like a Liara model I
saw something I didn't know the Liara
model but it looks like it looks like a
Liara model just like in a tea pose
I remember this mission being so cool ya
know you're like oh man like their whole
quad yeah we're all bantering off of
each other this is like oh now we got
one more person than usual cool and
these James of all people it stinks like
the worst one to have all of them I why
oh my god two of Baldwin Shepards this
is not good
ah III think it's a very fitting end
that we end this series by Baldwin
Shepherd having to kill himself thinking
about it something really poetic about
it no they've been kind of cool is if it
remembered uh your appearance in two and
showed that version so it would be three
hard verses to Shepard for us that would
be kind of cool that would be really rad
I understand like well yeah yeah the
tech of that I'm the lone wolf you were
always with I'm pretty sure we've
already been lonely a while and and
emotional but again like I just got the
failures there - never thought I'd say
but I'm looking forward to killing I
guess ominous threats of violence when
in our DNA but - Morgan I know trust me
I'm not a threat definitely not okay
we still got everyone
we're on the balcony it's just you I
guess Steve yep everyone's here
God oh you know consol this yeah nope
that gun is so good yep wait who are you
who is that guy looks like a girl no
detail on the face style who are you
that's Steve also low detail but who are
you let's look there other one
what's the other one sort of there James
James trainer or a Brookstone trainer
yeah yeah also those low-res they look
like paper mache models I know steam
hammer cover the play I think there were
supposed to be more banter during that
part probably maybe I think that's been
supposed to be more banter throughout
all of this is what we're talking at
this point eighty our whole squadron of
them and then the two other randos two
random people's on who there
haha I'll do of them go I'll cover you
oh yeah this means
Oh
[Music]
this chef really kept it all Scott oh
man I don't know are you sure you got
them all I feel like someone was
supposed to say something to that
the teams are just two people I guess
that's why they had the other like
random Alliance person yeah like well we
needed it said be another team team
hammerhead can't just leave Cortez God
Oh even Cortez da can do it just talking
[ __ ] to each other
those two ships Agia so fast
is there something kids are really bad
do you read me is anyone on this
frequency the short answer is no they're
not
what's the long answer to that the
longer answer involves your friend ah
their identity involves and forgotten
for well forever so just Steven James
okay whatever
been trying to kill them anyway yeah it
kind of works out my favorite feel I
will end you painfully shamefully the
second I get out of here I'm gonna take
your head and mount it in the Normandy
CIC [ __ ]
dark then I'm gonna mount his head next
to yours then I'm gonna take both of
your heads and space them up the airlock
I will assist you had Miranda I have her
mine has more but I'll shoot huh well
Miranda is dead so yeah I guess so yeah
I mean what's their plans like try stop
the Reapers and stuff Shepard like yeah
that's the thing is it seems like a
really bad time to try and steal the
efforts identity you've saved more alien
life than you have you I think I've
killed plenty of I mean I killed the
core hands and all I've seen you do is
end lives which I have not done ever
yeah actually he sounds like a like a
it's probably a better replacement
actually now if you'll excuse me the
Normandy need to the cap so I should go
oh
I've got room for Shepherd plus two and
figured out that because the other
Shepherd is stealing we can't bring this
V at the third person ah whoo - Oh whoo
- oh man
me not James right uh yeah no not James
actually yeah yeah I don't care what you
think James
yeah maybe take James we have a
different James boys chattering James
needy yells do that will have a
different voice chattering to us what to
come ha ha ha Joker we'll come back for
you I promise
I remember the original version is all
of them now they're like I never get
picked and Oh Jackie B to thank her by
herself back so good
[Music]
get back and pick up the up a sack right
get back to ugly a car huh
just get Liara you do not want to be in
my way mend a hose
oh great we shouldn't have brought him
God is turning a real uh James show huh
it is joke's on us I guess you kicked me
efficient with Benny and I'll time to
grab my toothbrush this is why uh I
can't fire you without a disciplinary
hearing trainer and really the first
thing you have is your toothbrush that
doesn't imply he doesn't want to fire
her typical trainer I've tried I've
looked into it it's a little more
complicated apparently I'll just get you
killed
it's easier that way Cerberus clone
Shepard it's uh yeah that's all I got
thanks James this is this is a James
show that's exactly what this is in lieu
of James is so stoked right now because
this is where he gets the make up for
all the missed opportunities he says
yeah lieu of everyone else he's dead
James gets to really shine trigger
engage would require extremely precise
Mass Effect feel manipulation
if you don't understand anything about a
toothbrush like Baldwin doesn't because
he never talked to her
yeah why why would give that joke you
wouldn't get it
Baldwin doesn't know that there's small
Mass Effect fields and their toothbrush
always Shepard barely knows your trainer
is because every time he had a message
he told her to [ __ ] off
gun sights on the Normandy is weird or
weird it's cool cool it's really cool
it's fitting right but yeah it's like a
fitting way to end mass effect man this
still feels really good it's R it's
really good I mean I were kind of
skipping through elements of it and
missing a lot of the dialogues but like
a man's little dialogue and this deal
tastes really good
yeah you get it in time an 800 face
fight oh dang oh boy wow that might be
an actual challenge for Aldrin nah
what am i dying about we got this thing
clouded clear your cuts with a jamming
focus head of it's just wrecked it's so
weird to see this dumb face throwing
grenades yeah like in my in my reticle
trying to Adam look Shepherd pie yeah
it's like Air Force one oh yeah
get off my plane actually this this
ending scene here is almost the exact
same as the classic movie of The Mummy
Returns to be very seen that film I have
but I don't remember it well at the end
they're both like hanging in the edge
and then like his wife comes and like
saves Brendan Fraser and then like emo
types like an ox una moon and Chile
doesn't come and get him just like that
yeah just like that
this isn't that he lets himself die
except we're not going to try and save
him
you you know it is yeah reflector that's
what I do hair for status Air Force One
the other options the some of your
returns when you save it you trying to
save him he just lets go I'm missing
come on des you shy so there are some
kills in this you get killed for the
color get points for the clone and oh
yeah yeah we got to die
oh man
[Music]
the rest of the squads waiting outside
ah one hour this is gonna yeah trainer
respect amazed we are oh come on maybe
we can take some actual time don't come
on everyone let's go I'd like you to
gather everyone else was supposed to be
Wow
that was good uh uh so after a hard day
spent fighting an evil clone you know
what comes next part Oh a nap please we
party down okay Edie and Cortez and
Trainor are in what I've also informed
dr. to Sony about any potential well
that's that's it literally everyone else
wait wait I'm in charge of again with
Shepherd there is no death button on
this thing there's there's no one else
to invite I invite the red again
no one invite no one else members of
your crew have expressed interest in
spending time with you commander yeah
I'm going to skip on our so now what
well it sounds like everyone's been
invited that can be invited everybody to
think that there are other people but I
don't think so so let's just do this man
yeah let's throw this party it's what
we've been waiting for I'm by my night
hearing any audio that would be why I
mean it was up though there's nothing
going on Oh God whoa that wasn't sound
no that was a game tapas written good
okay we got to go get party supplies
hopefully we won't need to travel across
the whole galaxy to different planets in
order to get snacks for
different people on our Oh ah never
finished that quest never finished that
game okay they're invited they're
invited they're invited they're invited
we can't uninvite any of them there's no
one else
so the throw this party yeah get this
started row party
what sort of party are you hoping to
have tonight commander I can set things
up for quiet conversation before would
you prefer a more energetic evening
really energetic energetic yeah we need
to make up for the lack of people here
hey come on it thanks for coming thanks
for the invite
ah make yourselves at home thank you
with Steve normally at the party oh yeah
well that's it everyone's here
what a what a crazy oh boy so stupid man
music is hot shut up
hey guys I'm a shepherd I'm attempting
to schmooze humans do house weather
today this isn't really much it's just
like two people hanging out inside what
uh what color socks do you guys wear
their own truth killing a killing your
friends lately I know all about that
taking down the collectors I've had
Tizen service gone lose and started
killing all their guns and all my guys
just everyone I killed the whole species
anyone relate I don't know if you guys
read about it in the newspaper you've
seen a lot of good times on that ship
haven't we
some of you more than others I'm just
honored you're not part of our group
she's like I'm glad I'm to be part of
your group all right that's it that was
it levar your guests appear to be
getting rowdy really are they are they
really let's get louder keep getting
louder darling let's turn it up let's
get turnt if there had been I just
killed a best shot at an alliance with a
Krogan I mean I kind of did I did that
okay for drinks next man what a lame
party it's so that's the thing about I
obviously know who you're expecting with
this like like yeah guys we'll get to
this party
it's like the party is great in the
normal when you play the game the way
you're supposed to play it like will we
an empty like hey guys thanks for
watching this video series with us
congratulations the end is super boring
because no one's ears on one occasion
you said that you wanted 200 trainer
trainer oh you were a I anyway I was
just joking
you know just the retrofit really like a
shepherd's not saying anything still
just listening like yeah don't mind me
pretend I'm not here
program check 49 great I get more
reliable result measuring pupil dilation
and thermal review ever watch needy
that's so creepy
there's vert trainer Edie has right that
mean I think they're all terrible this
is the situation of the guinea was kind
of used dropping at the time a body miss
voice you are all terrible Edie I
apologize for saying that I wanted to
roll naked with your voice in separation
what is it no whining in fact it was
flattered right I don't know about where
I wanted to grab your please stop
talking ah ah I think I'm leaving I'm
leaving I'm leaving your conversation is
weird
don't guests appear to be enjoying
themselves commander
yeah a little too much check on them or
dance dance
probably yeah turn up the music and get
some people dancing
good dance yeah great now that
for a highly amusing extra material
okay that's cheating not talking about
blackmail I know about that remember
what I did with the Krogan race
blackmail where's some dancing
[Applause]
you should bring out those moves more
often trainer sister so this is the
lamest party I've ever been to
please be assured that I have full
access to the fire prevention I'm lame
parties too I love those okay whatever
all right after Nam dark it's very to
yesterday well I like a commander it's
good to see you cut loose now and then
thank you all for your loyalty and
support weird this is so stupid
do you find it relaxing oh why does that
mean okay you've had your fun put me
down now come on let's dance
I didn't realize how really sexual this
hold on is also what you were looking
away right when it just started out of
Noah [ __ ] that's good
how's the idea feel secure they are yeah
yeah I'm really really drunk
I just like hey photos I'm already at
the photo Wow that's because normally
you got to like there's like 15
conversations per yeah Wow okay this is
so sad so sad just like the artist is
[ __ ] trashed changing really really
into it
god I love you [ __ ] let's get a photo to
remember this arrange yourselves on the
sofa an excellent suggestion Shepard
great idea I want a copy thanks for
coming everyone here's to us all five of
us show it show me this start out the
beautiful photo okay everyone say
Normandy Normandy that's the photo oh
wow whoo is everything I hoped it could
be damn that was depressing I think we
honestly lived up to our name there was
the ad party you sad as party on the
Citadel here we are one night on at the
final episode of saddest party on the
Citadel it's been a great ride thank you
to all those who have been following us
in watching us leaving comments
following the Baldwin Shepherd Twitter
account it's been a lot of fun yeah I
really appreciate everyone who's been
looking forward to the episodes every
week even on the weeks where we couldn't
get them out because we've been so busy
but yeah we've been doing this in our
spare time and it's something that we do
because we just really liked it and I'm
glad I'm glad it you know I think it
actually turned out pretty well
ending I was a look that party was
really sad but that's what we were going
really boring but man that's what we
wanted and honestly the game delivered
on that front yeah some of the sort of
things with the during the story
missions for that DLC were really funny
yeah I it was a good ride but anyway for
more stuff like this make sure to hit
that subscribe button and for one last
time I'm Jake and as John Luke make sure
to follow us on Twitter and of course
follow good old Baldwin Shepard on
Twitter although I don't know how much
he'll be tweeting after this but we'll
see
who knows we'll see all right now enjoy
this final roll of all of our character
deaths
yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]